la société c'est un hôpital
psychiatrique à celui ouvert c'est pas
que les SDF les SDF ça concentré
du M bonsoir
alors cette semaine les restos du cœur
ont lancé leur 27e campagne depuis
l'appel de Coluche les sous populaires
les foyers d'hébergement le monde de la
rue vous avez vécu tout ça pendant près
de 10 ans Frédéric comme beaucoup
d'autres mais vous vous l'avez écrit au
fil des années vous êtes devenu le
premier SDF écrivain alors aujourd'hui
vous publiez chez Edilivre petite
douceur acidulées vous racontez la rue
vos jeux de mots beaucoup de gueule vous
nous raconterez votre histoire à 20h OK
[Musique]
alors Frédéric dum rebonsoir vous
publiez chez Eddie livre petite douceur
acidulées où vous racontez votre vie
dans la rue vous êtes donc le premier
écrivain SDF vous êtes né le 9 octobre
1972 à Boulogne-sur-Mer dans le
Pas-de-Calais père ouvriers fraiseur
mère femme au foyer milieu modeste dans
lequel les incompréhensions laissent
souvent place à des disputes plus
violentes en effet votre mère a eu votre
frère aîné à l'âge de 16 ans et elle
n'était pas prête pour être maman
16 ans c'est jeune ouais il y a un autre
sujet de discorde qui est beaucoup plus
grave c'est l'adultère qui est une
véritable gangrène conjugale qui se
termine en tragédie puisque votre père
tu la mentes sa femme
vous avez 3 ans à l'époque
vous avez des souvenirs de ça donc je
les suis plus tard
votre père est emprisonné vous restez
votre frère et vous avec votre mère qui
est complètement déstructuré qui a
beaucoup de mal à s'occuper de vous et
là livrer à vous-même vous commencez à
faire des conneries comme tous les
jeunes qui sont un peu désorrés oui
vous traînez dans la rue sans
surveillance
jusqu'au jour où vous mettez le feu à la
maison j'avais mon petit quand même
pompier j'ai craqué les allumettes et
puis je pensais pouvoir éteindre le feu
avec ce [__] de camion mais non les
vrais pompiers sont venus
je commence très fort pyromane
les services sociaux finissent par
prendre le relais de votre mère et à 7
ans vous vous retrouvez Frédéric dans
une famille d'accueil vous dites en fait
on m'a pas éduqué quoi
c'était des gens qui
m'ont pas éduqué qui était là pour
l'argent et qui n'offre aucun amour
ouais c'est une éducation à l'ancienne
avec Martine
existait plus quoi c'était des UV donc
j'étais un peu la risée de la cour de
récréation tous vos camarades vous
traitent comme un comme un bâtard un
crève la fin et en plus des trous les
roues ça pue quand il pleut Paul de
carottes alors vous passez ainsi d'une
enfance turbulente à la délinquance vous
devenez un bagarreur et vous vous battez
même avec les avec les profs tuer des
excès de violence tout à fait
et tout ça vous enfonce encore plus dans
la révolte évidemment dans la
délinquance
en 1987 c'est le coup de grâce votre
père avec qui vous entreteniez de bonnes
relations depuis sa sortie de prison se
suicide
alors vous dites lorsque mon père s'est
suicidé je suis parti en vrai quoi là ça
y est c'est ouais j'ai passé une année
une très mauvaise année en plus c'était
une année où je vais passer mon CAP
Menuisier et bon ben
je suis j'ai rien foutu quoi le décès de
mon père m'a énormément
touché
affaibli à 18 ans c'est l'armée et là
vous croyez que cela va vous aider à
vous structurer mais en fait à part le
permis de conduire ça vous arrive à
apporter quoi beaucoup plus de révoltes
incompréhension parce que les appeler du
contingent on était pris un peu pour des
larbins oui c'est ça et on vous fait
laver un sol et quand vous l'avez laver
on vous dit relève-le voilà ouais mais
moi je suis mon côté rebelle a fait que
je disais non mais moi c'est fait c'est
fait j'ai rien contre vos ordres j'ai
rien contre la hiérarchie il en faut
mais non j'ai dit non ça suffit quoi
des des semaines de prison
alors voilà ensuite vous refusez de
partir dans les Balkans où on vous
propose de monter des gardes à
l'aéroport de Zagreb et vous dites j'ai
pas envie de prendre une balle dans la
tête pour 3000 balles par mois quoi
finalement parce que peut-être que
l'armée si vous étiez resté je voudrais
pas connu la rue déjà ouais à votre
sortie de l'armée vous trouvez un boulot
de serveur voilà ça se passe pas mal
vous bossez beaucoup 10 à 15 heures par
jour mais ça s'arrange c'est-à-dire vous
avez des copains en fait des fesses en
bois c'est dans les bars
un peu trop mais en fait c'est qu'une
illusion parce qu'au bout de trois mois
vous êtes licencié oui sans préavis son
bulletin de salaire voilà on fera un
procès à votre patron que vous gagnerez
enfin vous êtes de nouveau dans la merde
quoi c'est le début de la rue finalement
c'est le début de la chute alors là vous
décidez d'aller retrouver votre mère
dans le Lot-et-Garonne mais les
retrouvailles tournent au cauchemar et
votre mère finira par rappeler la police
vous mettre à la porte violent quand
même ça ouais c'est violent et c'est à
dire que ma mère elle avait l'impression
de
d'accueillir un enfant de 7 ans l'enfant
qu'elle avait laissé à la DASS à l'âge
de 7 ans j'en avais plus 7 quoi
alors vous dites je m'attendais à
rebondir mais ça n'a pas marché
effectivement et là vous venez pour de
vrai SDF en première nuit dans un
presbytère il est plus dans les draps
vous dormez pas et au petit matin vous
vous dites je vais pas vivre comme ça
quoi et vous décidez de prendre la route
en fait quand ça va où je vais sans
savoir où ça mène parce que je
connaissais aucune ficelle de la rue
accueille de jour accueille de nuit
structures
ce qu'on populace quoi catholique la
Croix-Rouge je connaissais aucune
ficelle de tout ça et donc je volais
dans les supermarchés pour pouvoir
mourir
vous dormez dans les cages d'escalier
dans les halls de gare mais vous dites
le plus dur en fait dans cette villa
c'est les paumées c'est à dire les
schizos les mythos les paranos les
psychos vous dites la rue est un hôpital
psychiatrique à ciel ouvert dont les
patients ne sont pas suivis médicalement
la société c'est un hôpital
psychiatrique à ce nouvel ouverte c'est
pas que SDF les SDF ça concentré voilà
on vous dites en plus quand il se soigne
c'est avec du cannabis de l'héroïne du
crack Subutex alcool
pour vous c'est plutôt l'alcool
tu fais 10 cures et trois postes cures
alors il y a aussi de bons moments
d'amitié ce très touchant cette
bouteille de Château Latour 74 oui
une bouteille autant voulait une bonne
bouteille
à 800 balles que j'ai eu aussi fait avec
un jeune polonais qui avec qui
[Musique]
et vous faites la même chose mais sans
faute d'orthographe et vous mettez à
faire la manche et ça rapporte quand
même 300 balles par jour quoi mais la
première fois oui j'étais assez surpris
bon les pièces de 10 balles tombaient
tomber tomber tomber j'ai fait 300
balles en une après-midi c'est faux et
en 1997 vous rencontrez Caroline votre
amour va durer 4 ans mais comme souvent
dans votre vie Frédéric ça termine mal
ouais elle se suicide
évidemment vous devenez vagabond alors
là c'est vous prenez un vélo une toile
de temps une canne à pêche une radio
vous partez sur la route alors direction
la forêt de Brocéliande vous voulez voir
la tombe de Merlin l'enchanteur c'est
joli ça
et puis bon ben j'avais un petit papier
Signé Caroline elle disait je t'aime on
avait fait une empreinte puis je l'ai
mis je l'ai mis dans la fente de la
tombe histoire de faire un peu le deuil
quoi de passer à autre chose mais
t'as pas été évident ici là vous
commencez à noter vos pensées sur un
calepin vous dites j'écrivais tout ce
qui me passait par la tête voilà et
votre passion pour l'écriture redouble
quand vous récupérez un dictionnaire un
petit Robert qui date de 2001 année de
décès de Caroline et ce dictionnaire je
l'ai touché de A à Z j'ai pris un petit
carnet j'ai marqué les mots que j'aimais
les côtés positifs et les côtés négatifs
parallèlement vous rencontrez Michel
Roumégoux future mère UMP de Cahors et
là vous devenez militant quand vous ça y
est vous avez trouvé une aventure qui
vous intéresse et là vous êtes très
content c'est le 18 décembre 2006 quand
Nicolas Sarkozy déclare que d'ici à deux
ans plus personne ne dormira sur un
trottoir et mourra de froid vous y
croyez au départ
au départ ouais je dis ben c'est ouais
c'est super c'est bien quelqu'un qui
s'occupe des sans domicile fait exprès
voilà puis après il y a le Fouquet il y
a l'iode de Bolloré là vous commencez à
déchanter quand même c'est un peu mon
cul c'est du poulet quoi ouais
voilà donc le rêve
UMP
s'évapore ici là qu'on vous offre un
dictionnaire des synonymes et là vous
découvrez vraiment une passion pour
l'écriture vous dites ce dictionnaire
des synonymes c'est une mine d'or ouais
c'est un livre magique et il y a des
mots il y a des mots des jolis mots quoi
des
j'ai joué j'ai joui avec les mots aussi
vous avez un petit gobelet devant vous
les gens mettent des euros s'ils ont
envie mais vous vous en foutez vous êtes
dans votre dictionnaire ça vous
passionne quoi c'était une façon de
d'échapper à leur regard bien sûr vous
oubliez tout autour de vous à ce
moment-là je suis dans mon monde alors
voilà finalement votre livre petite
douceur acidulée ce qui est pas un
mauvais titre d'ailleurs sera publié par
Eddy livres et vous dites je revendique
le prix littéraire du culot on peut être
malheureux et se cultivé extraordinaire
alors aujourd'hui voilà vous bossez vous
replier des cages d'escalier dans les
quartiers difficiles
ça va là ça se passe bien sauf quand les
mecs viennent taguer ce que vous
repeignez en fait ouais mais moi ça
touche pas mon salaire je m'en fous quoi
c'est tout quoi alors vous suivez une
thérapie et vous êtes amoureux de Marie
on arrive c'est génial mon petit canari
vous dites la rue je veux pas y
retourner d'ailleurs j'ai jeté mon sac à
dos et mon duvet fini symboliquement je
vais faire Nicolas si on devait
récupérer ce qui est pas très honnête
mais le discours magnifique de ce
monsieur on est un petit peu agacé par
cette tendance politique qui consiste à
mettre l'accent sur les assistes ils ont
qu'à se bouger il faut qu'il fasse
quelque chose et quand on entend le
déterminisme on sent bien qu'il y a pas
de complaisance qui sont des mots que
j'entends dans les dîners mondains
ils se complètent finalement dans la
paresse dans l'alcoolisme dans le
chômage dans tout ça je je pense que
quand on fait un gros plan sur ce
monsieur on voit bien que ça a pas été
une partie de plaisir un mot Laurent il
y a juste un truc quand même qui me
frappe c'est que le seul vrai social
c'est le moment où il y a des gens qui
vraiment se posent et sont à côté de
nous et je crois que ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit pas oublier parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on fait plus de
social on file des prestations on se
donne bonne conscience on fait plus de
social la vraie façon d'aider c'est le
moment il y a quelqu'un qui se pose et
qui vous accompagne vraiment pour
reprendre confiance pour finir si vous
avez une phrase de votre livre que vous
auriez dire là un inforiasme
[Musique]
à lui de tolérer ce que l'intolérance ne
tolère pas ouais j'aime bien cette
phrase aussi bien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu